hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make
learning math a lot less stressful so in
this video what we're going to talk
about is how to find the equation of a
parabola when you're given just the
vertex and the directrix so just to show
you just how parabolas look it's a
u-shaped graph there's a directrix a
focus and a vertex and the one thing we
want to watch is that the vertex is
halfway in between the focus and the
directrix the distance from the vertex
to the directrix or the vertex to the
focus that distance is called P and it's
the focal distance so that's the basic
setup of a parabola and it can be
written in two forms it can be written
in x squared equals 4p Y or Y squared
equals 4p X if the x squared is the
squared term then it's going to be
opening up or down depending if P is
positive or negative and if it's a Y
squared form it's going to be opening to
the right or to the left and depending
again if Y is the p value is positive or
negative so I'll show you what I mean in
some examples here so here we've got the
vertex is at 2 4 and the directrix is at
y equals negative 2 so here's our
directrix y equals negative 2 here's our
vertex ok at 2 4 and our focus is going
to be because this distance here is the
same as the distance from the vertex to
the focus our focus is going to be up
here so this distance is 1 2 3 4 5 6 so
this would also be 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok and
our parabola is going to look like this
ok and we can see it's going to be
opening up and down so that's going to
be an x squared variety so it's going to
be like this x squared equals 4p y and
it's opening up so P is going to be
positive and P is going to be 6 the
distance from the vertex to the focus ok
so that's going to be 24 y ok but this
is if it's centered at the origin this
has been shifted to the right 2 and up 4
so this is actually going to be X minus
2 squared
and 24 times y minus 4
okay so shifting right 2 up 4 and our
p-value is 6 that's the distance from
the vertex to the focus or the vertex to
the directrix now another interesting
point that sometimes students ask about
is how do I know you know what are some
additional points so I can get a good
graph of my parabola and that's where
this value here comes in the 4p at the
level of the focus the parabola is going
to be 4p wide so in this case it's going
to be 24 units wide right here so if I
go to the right 12 units I'm just going
to estimate and if I go to the left 12
units that will give me a sense of how
wide the parabola is okay at the level
of the focus so this distance right here
is 4p so I'll show you another link okay
up here with the cards to some other
videos about parabolas that I have to
get more into depth about how to solve
these problems but I just want to show
you a quick example on how to get the
equation when you're just given the
vertex and the directrix I think it
really comes down to sketching the graph
and finding that p value the distance
from the vertex to the directrix or the
vertex to the focus so subscribe to the
channel check out some of my past videos
and I'll see you in the next video I'll
talk to you soon